David Cay Johnston author of perfectly
legal on this March xxx one we're taping
this I picked up the Washington Post and
I'll read you the following first
paragraph on a story by Jonathan Weisman
President Bush's 2004 budget request for
the Internal Revenue Service would
seriously shortchange the agency's tax
collection activities leaving
half-a-million delinquent tax accounts
uncollected 15 million service calls
unanswered and nearly 46,000 audits
unscheduled according to the president's
own IRS oversight board and as I read
the rest of the article your whole book
is in this story well in fact the report
actually quotes my book and I have the
same story and then in the New York
Times this morning although frankly my
lead is not quite as compelling as that
one so what is this book about
this book is about the reality of how
our tax system actually operates
after the politicians have passed the
laws the the news media do a good job of
telling you the official version of
events and what politicians in
Washington say about taxes but I've
spent a lot of my career covering
Washington without being there by paying
attention to what actually government
does as opposed to what the politicians
say that it does and I show in this book
that our tax system is not what most
people think most people believe that
the higher your income the greater the
share of your income you pay in taxes
and that those who are the most
successful provide benefits for those
who don't do as well and what I show in
the book is something I was astonishing
to me to learn in fact I hired a
graduate student economics to double
check all of the findings and that is
that the middle class and the upper
middle class people making fifty to five
hundred thousand dollars a year actually
subsidize the richest people in America
now this was not historically true but
they do now the IRS just today came out
this morning with new statistical tables
on income for the year 2001 and on the
way over here I was calculating and the
6800 Americans who make more than ten
million dollars a year pay a smaller
percentage of their income 25 percent in
federal income taxes than people who
make four
five hundred thousand dollars a year and
when you add in Social Security taxes
people making seventy to eighty thousand
dollars a year are paying a larger share
of their income to the federal
government than people who make ten
million dollars a year more whose fault
is that and is there anything wrong with
it
well fault I'm not sure quite the word I
would use the responsibility for dis
Congress article 1 section 8 of the
Constitution says that Congress shall
have the power to lay and collect taxes
and it's a virtually unlimited power
it's a political issue in America what
taxes are what's wrong with it I don't
think most Americans if they knew that
they are subsidizing people who make as
much in a year or a month as they will
in a lifetime would be very happy about
that but it is not what most Americans
understand because our national myth is
something quite different our national
myth is as I described before the
highest income americans subsidize the
rest of us and it's just not true and
this is a change that's taken place over
the last thirty years both Democrats and
Republicans brought it about let me get
into some of the names in your book at
one point and I don't remember exactly
what he said yeah you might've even
thanked Suzy whet Laufer
for helping us better understand
something about Jack Welsh now the most
people know that whole story is got run
far it's gotten very personal but what
was it you're talking about in the book
well I didn't thank her but I described
that that unintentionally in her role as
editor of the Harvard Business Review
she had brought to light in a way that
people could understand one of what I
think are the abusive practices in the
tax system and that is the subsidy that
you and I provide to senior executives
who fly around in the company jet they
pay about a penny a mile as a practical
matter to fly in the luxury of a company
jet the real cost of that flight is
several dollars a mile in many cases
five or six dollars a mile and that cost
is charged to the shareholders and then
taken as a deduction so when a CEO
travels coast to coast in the company
jet he pays
two hundred and sixty dollars the real
cost is more in the neighborhood of
fifteen to seventeen thousand dollars
and so you and I as taxpayers were at
five thousand dollars of that money and
this was done under the guise of
middle-class tax relief in 1985 it's
just a perfect example of how Congress
says you know we're out here to help
ordinary Americans and in fact they
weren't they were out helping CEOs you
get into some detail about the kind of
plane that is at Jack Welch's call I
guess a 737 business jet it's you know
you and I probably have often flown in
Boeing 737s many viewers have they see
typically about 120 people General
Electric's has a bedroom suite with a
shower and a sitting room in a boardroom
and seating for a small number of people
and when Jack Welch was running General
Electric and being extraordinarily well
paid he put together a fortune during
those years of more than a half a
billion dollars
he had the unbridled use of those
airplanes including for personal use and
because the company took the position
that his security required that he fly
in company transportation he never fly
commercial like you and I there's a
special tax break for that in the last
year that he had a contract negotiated
with the company there was a single line
in the contract in the footnote that
said something like upon his retirement
he shall continue to enjoy the benefits
he had well in office well it turns out
that those benefits were according to
the wife who divorced him over his
affair with Suzy well offer about 2.7
million dollars a year in value just for
the jet and there were other perks that
went along with us after I explained the
economics of this in an article in The
New York Times
mr. Welch the next day has said that he
decided that he would pay for these
perks he then wrote an op-ed piece for
The Wall Street Journal about it he then
appeared on all sorts of TV shows and
spoke to lots of reporters but not to me
not that I blame him I cost
a lot of money if she hadn't done the
interview and written the article in the
Harvard Business Review well would we
have ever known this well we knew it
because I had reported previously in the
New York Times but it didn't have any
impact or mean anything to people I mean
that's one of the important issues here
about tax you can tell people all day
long about Drive public policy issues
and to some people people who watch
c-span it may resonate but to millions
of Americans it doesn't it's when you
can bring things to life through the
example of an individual and his case
and what that individual did or a group
of people and give a human face to it
that you can bring meaning to public
policy and that's why and perfectly
legal much of the book is told through
the lives of individual Americans who
for good or bad encountered the tax
system but on the corporate jet thing
who pays who ends up paying for Jack
Welsh who's retired to have a jet at his
disposal all over the world all year
long the shareholders of General
Electric pay and then they get to deduct
that on the corporate tax return so you
and I as taxpayers share in the cost of
that why is this happened well and how
much of it goes on well great deal goes
on there are 9,000 corporate jets in
this country and there have been lots of
news stories that I have read and some
which I've written about executives who
use the company jet as a personal taxi
and we know that Ken Lay's daughter used
one of the Enron jets to fly her bed
across the North Atlantic because it
wouldn't fit in baggage on a commercial
jetliner we know that during the RJR
nabisco matter there was a flight on one
of the company planes where the manifest
said the passenger was g shepard as in
german shepherd dog we also learned in
the adelphia trial that the Regas family
had a Christmas tree flown to New York
from counter sport Pennsylvania if I
remember right papers work yeah right
well if it doesn't cost you anything to
do something of course you use it I mean
that's one of the fundamentals of
economics if something is virtually a
free good you will make a great deal of
use of it if if c-span put at your
disposal tomorrow Brian a corporate jet
and
set here we have a Gulfstream 5 for you
can stand up and walk around it my guess
is you would be off to Florida or Los
Angeles more even if you weren't
inclined to do so just because it's
there it's virtually free and you know
it's it originally wasn't even in the
law that this was the case in 1985
there was a debate which I recount in
perfectly legal on the floor of the
Senate where Senator Packwood from
Oregon came and said I have here this
bill there's nothing else in it except
relief for the poor middle class
taxpayer who has to keep excessive
amounts of Records if he uses for
personal use a company car and it's just
an outrage and people are rightly upset
about this and we're going to fix this
and Senator Metzenbaum from Ohio a man
wealthy enough to own his own personal
jet maybe he does I don't know came on
the front said well wait wait a second
that's not quite true attached to this
bill is a report that tells the IRS to
value the personal use of company jets
by executives not at the first-class or
charter rates that were in effect but at
these artificially low rates that work
out now to be about a penny a mile for a
jet you can stand up and walk around and
on a long trip and that's indicative of
what's happened to the tax code that
that there are it is just larded with
all of these provisions that benefit a
very narrow range of people and that you
and i are forced in part to share in the
cost of is there any connection with all
this that politicians you're running for
office and all are not even running for
office get the corporate jets at the
cost of a first-class ticket to go from
Washington to all over the country well
they get it for a lot less than the cost
of that but yes in fact many members of
Congress routinely get ferried around
the country in corporate jets by people
who are seeking favours from Washington
and I don't have a jet to provide a
congressman with that kind of benefit
and Anor his good favor but there's a
secondary benefit to this which is you
know most Americans if they ever meet a
member of Congress or senator it's hi
I'm running for office and I'd like your
vote that's the end of the discussion
but now think about a year you're
pressing some piece of legislation or
your friends are and
you're flying a member of Congress out
for the weekend so he can give a speech
to some group on the other end of the
country you've got five or six hours
with him or somebody on your staff does
you have an opportunity to explain and
petition the government for your redress
of grievances and that together with the
direct campaign contributions are
resulting in a government that is
focused on and thinking about the
concerns of the very best off people in
America and we keep seeing legislation
introduced and if you listen carefully
the remarks of congressmen and Senators
they're not focused on ordinary
Americans those are sort of throwaway
lines they are focused on and the laws
they are passing are focused on relief
for the already best off I'm not sure
about this but I'll bet somebody's
watching this right now saying that
reporter from The New York Times is a
screaming socialist well in fact in my
book I inveigh against the danger that
our tax system will turn us into
socialists if we were to adopt the flat
tax and I'm sure that we'll find many
people find jarring one of the things
about about my book I have sat on panels
with left and right wing tax economist
experts in the field and all they do is
sit there and agree with what's in the
book the book is not ideological it is
descriptive of what is happening and I
have no antipathy to wealth I have no
one to hide
I think we would be a better country if
we had more wealth and we had more
people with high incomes you know on
another show somebody asked me a matter
that's a matter of public record and
I'll go to that which is you know I'm a
registered Republican so that my book
isn't is not about promoting any
ideology I don't propose a solution to
our tax problem except that people
become actively involved in the job of
being citizens so that we have a
government that reflects the interests
of all of us not a narrow group of us
and one of the things that isn't in the
book but maybe is an important
historical point because I've studied
taxes all the way back to the Pharaohs
you know it's the Pharaohs from whom we
get the phrase they'll what are they
going to do beat it out of you yes if
you couldn't pay your taxes to the
Pharaoh you could go to his priests and
they would give you a beating it's
because of a grant of tax relief by a
pharaoh that we understand
hieroglyphics because that's what the
rosetta stone is when you read the text
of it it is a grant of tax relief Athens
at one time had a flat tax and when it
did it was a tyranny then the Athenians
went to taxing based on ability to pay
and democracy flourished the father of
capitalism Adam Smith said taxes should
be based on ability to pay and he said
that before Karl Marx was born every
classic conservative economic thinker
that I have read and I've read more than
a hundred books on the history of
taxation on history's related to
taxation has come to it's clear to me
the same conclusion taxes should be
based on ability to pay and what we're
seeing going on now in this country is
not classic well-founded conservative
thinking about taxes we are seeing
radical ideas that are being passed off
that are a historical the phrase that I
read most often in your book is
political donor class yeah political
donor class what is it
well that's they wanted about 850
Americans who are very important
campaign contributors these are the
people who get real access you know you
and I get the hello in the mall from the
lawmaker these are people who they
themselves are donors and they bring a
lot of other money with them and they
get to sit down and in detail present
the government through Congress with
what their concerns are after I finished
the book I got off the plane one day at
LaGuardia and a former state senator
from a very wealthy family was there and
there was a shortage cab so we shared a
cabin and I was articulating to him on
the way into Manhattan my political
donor class theory and he said to me Oh
David you're being much too kind to
people like me I go what and he says you
know all the years I was in office I
knew every day who my 10 biggest donors
were and that I had to be demonstrating
to them every day that I was working on
their behalf and I might never get what
they want
in some cases I don't think you could
ever get what they wanted but I had to
show them that or they were gonna take
their money and all the other money they
represented and go to the other guy and
then he said you know I don't think I
ever once looked in the mirror when I
was shaving and said what am i doing
day for the average person I represent
well the proof of that enormous
influence that this group has because of
the campaign donor system I think his
she'll know what happened after 9/11 two
days after 9/11 Congress came back into
session and there were ten big bills
introduced to deal with 9/11 and one of
them was a tax bill now what kind of tax
benefit do the firefighters and the
police officers who went into the World
Trade Center and who now have left
widows and orphans need what about the
the busboy who was in the top of the
World Trade Center at the windows in the
world restaurant or the army sergeants
and majors sitting at their desks over
here with the Pentagon
well Congress thought that what they
needed was a state tax relief because
that's what Congress is thinking about
you know you every politician of the day
you can't buy my vote I accept that
what you can buy is access and if the
only people with real meaningful access
are the political donor class and
particularly within that a group of
people who do not want to pay taxes who
are Verint ly anti-tax then over time
that's what numbers of Congress are
going to think about and we're seeing in
the laws the results of that that a
family that makes seventy eighty
thousand dollars people in that range on
average pay as much or more of their
income to the federal government as
people who make an average of twenty
five million dollars a year that's the
new data that's came out this morning
that I think that that's an outrage and
I think most Americans would not approve
of that system if they understood when
you said a state tax that named Frank
Luntz jumped right out in front of me I
mean a frank luntz is a strategist he's
a hired gun he works for the Republicans
he worked for Pat Buchanan and Ross
Perot and Rudy Giuliani and he worked
for Newt Gingrich and he does MSNBC know
he does does he
all right and he is the one who's
popularized the term the death tax and
it's astonishing around for ordinary
reporters you know refer to the death
tax in their news accounts there is no
death tax in America there's an estate
tax it is a tax on the right to transfer
wealth from your pocket after you've
done
to someone else there's also a gift tax
if you do it while you're alive it is
similar to the system of if you own
stock in Company A and you sell it and
there's been a gain you have to pay
capital gains taxes on it only applies
to a narrow segment of the public it's a
segment that has grown somewhat because
Congress has as it often does seen as a
moneymaker and has not adjusted it to
reflect the fact that millions of people
now own their retirement assets instead
of getting a pension so that gets
counted in their estate and the enormous
run-up in housing values in America but
if you right now if you're a married
couple and you have two million dollars
you don't pay the estate tax I have
interviewed people who believe
especially new immigrants that in
America when you die the government
comes into your home and takes half of
what you have it's been very successful
now when we interviewed Frank Luntz
about this and he explained how he sold
this and how to ask questions in a way
that gets people to go for this one of
the questions that was asked in the
survey is something like since the
estate tax represents second and third
and fourth and even fifth taxation of
the same dollar and since it discourages
economic activity and it's unfairly
applied are you in favor of it or
against it and shockingly only about
seventy nine percent of Americans were
against it I mean based on that question
a hundred percent of Americans what you
would think would be against it he also
however told us that if he was working
for the Democrats or for those
Republicans who want to retain the
estate tax
he would have labeled it the
billionaires tax and what is today it's
only the Ted Turner's of the world who
paid this tax he would have said let's
raise the exemption to ten million
dollars because it's a nice round figure
and only apply it to people above that
because most Americans can envision
having a million dollars but ten is
certainly beyond their their can in a
billion circles that when you talk about
inheritance or state tax and the tax
bill that President Bush pushed through
Congress you discuss all this in here
and go up to what year is it what's the
optimum year of all this that it when it
when does it die when's the well the
estate tax goes out for a single year
2010
and you know Paul Krugman's referred to
it as the throw mama from the Train
bill and I have no doubt and I've talked
to many estate tax lawyers who agree
that they've had clients who will be
plotting if that's the way the law
remains to figure out how to get rid of
an ailing parent in December instead of
January the next year when there will be
estate taxes interestingly in the year
2000 there was a bill introduced in
Congress that would have given immediate
estate tax relief would have reduced the
number of people paying estate tax by
probably seventy five percent it got
almost no coverage the neither the
National Federation of Independent
Business of the American Farm Bureau
told their members about it I called up
the NFIB and asked them for the names of
five or six businessmen who they thought
were well-informed in this issue and
when I told each one of them that there
was an offer of immediate estate tax
relief for million dollars for a couple
every single one of these guys said we'd
go for that in a minute and I said well
what about the principle here that we
shouldn't have an estate tax and I said
I don't know what principle you know
this is a very practical matter they
didn't see it as a principle matter they
saw this practical matter so a bird in
the hand was turned down however let me
point out that from now until 2010
what a terrific moneymaker for those
politicians who want to exploit this
issue what a way to raise funds what is
and I read your chapter on this I need
to talk through this what is the
alternative minimum tax and how does it
apply mean how can we understand what it
applies to us and what who's in danger
of having to pay that well I paid it
this year if you look on line 43 of your
tax return you may have paid it if
you're a married couple with two or more
children you make seventy five two
hundred thousand dollars a year there's
a 97% chance you're going to be paying
it within the next two years and 42
percent of the people on that group are
going to lose all of their Bush tax cuts
the alternative minimum tax is a
parallel universe it's kind of like a
Star Trek episode you know there's the
good Captain Kirk over here and there's
the evil Captain Kirk over here and
if you fall into the alternative minimum
tax you lose various deductions because
it is designed to make sure that you
have to pay some income tax when it was
enacted in 1969 in its original form it
was to make sure that 155 high-income
Americans people are made the equivalent
of a million dollars a year in today's
dollars couldn't get away with paying
zero income tax well it's failed because
now the numbers up to more than 300 but
it has certainly caused a lot of people
in that group to pay more in tax than
they would in 1986 when we had
bipartisan tax reform that broadened the
base and lowered the tax rates the
alternative tax was changed to plug a
little hole they were about a billion
dollars short of having revenue from the
old system revenue from the new one so
it was changed to make as things you
lose because they're tax shelters your
exemption for yourself for your spouse
for your children your deduction for
your state income taxes your deduction
for your local property taxes the
standard deduction the most passive
thing you can do under this law Congress
will even tax you if you have a
seriously ill child or you yourself or
seriously ill if you spend ten percent
or more of your income on medical bills
you will pay additional taxes because
that's what Congress has decided to do
and in the book I tell about the the
Claussen family and how because they
have a son with cancer they have been
taxed and mr. Clausen who's a lawyer
it's just he says how could this
possibly be how could Congress do this
and and I've got dozens of statements
from congressmen and Senators in my desk
drawer saying this is an outrage but
nobody's fixed it well because of the
way the Bush tax cuts interact with the
alternative minimum tax and because
there was no reform of the alternative
minimum tax when the Bush tax cuts were
passed more and more Americans are going
to shift over into the alternative tax
universe by 2010 and maybe as early as
2008 because we've speeded up the the
cuts about thirty-five million Americans
out of the 130 million house
that file tax returns are going to fall
into the alternative minimum tax
basically if you make fifty thousand
five hundred thousand dollars it will
become the de-facto tax system for you
and all of the money that that raises a
half trillion dollars of increased
alternative tax and by President Bush's
standards this is a half trillion dollar
tax increase is being used by the
government to finance the tax cuts for
the super-rich for those people who are
making three million dollars a year and
more so that they can pay a thirty five
percent rate instead of a thirty nine
point six percent rate so you know if
you're one of those people who thinks
you should be having money taken out of
your pocket by the government to help
the super-rich it's a great system who
doesn't have to worry about is there any
way to get mean guess what's and what's
the percentage of tax under the
alternative minute of minimum tax well
it has two rates twenty six and twenty
eight percent but the tax base is
different the rate on what you pay is
different so line forty-three will tell
you how much additional tax you're
paying because of it I think one year my
wife and I because we sold a little
rental property we had I think we paid
$16,000 that wiped out more than wiped
out any any chance we had of making any
profit of it in the investment
interestingly well there's a lot of talk
about family friendly tax policy in
Washington you are about thirty times
more likely to pay the alternative
minimum tax if you have two or more
children than if you're single or have
no children so that's who it hits it
hits families very hard because you lose
the exemption for yourself your spouse
and your children if you're like me I
have I have eight children although only
two of them are still tax deductions if
I had all eight of my children I would
be paying lots of alternative minimum
tax and the age range on those eight
children thirteen 2:37 you and your wife
what's her name Jennifer Leonard where
did you meet her
jennifer and i jennifer is not my first
wife she's the mother of my two younger
children and we've been married let's
see this is March 30th 21 years 10
months and 30 days today we were fixed
up on a blind date by United Way in Los
Angeles and why in 90 I had a friend who
worked
there I was an investigative reporter at
the Los Angeles Times I was covering the
Los Angeles Police Department I was the
first reporter to seriously examine the
Los Angeles Police Department and was my
story's essentially changed its image
from this a badge 714 efficient honest
straightforward Police Department to
show how it actually was operating and
as we now know it's now running run
under the aegis of the federal
government hell I even own the New York
Times
nine years and why do you live in
Rochester New York well my wife Jennifer
Leonard to whom the book is dedicated is
the president of the Community
Foundation in Rochester there are 600
Community Foundation's around the
country they are as opposed to United
ways where you give your money and
immediately gets up to social services
these are endowments and I think eight
hundred and some families in Rochester
have funds including my wife and I have
a little tiny fund to provide permanent
charitable capital for the welfare of
that community and where did you grow up
well I grew up in California I was born
in San Francisco grew up in various
towns up and down the coast my
grandmother had a little tiny orange
ranch in Orange California we moved to
Santa Cruz on the coast when I was 12
and I guess I regard that as home when
did you leave it California no Santa
Cruz Santa Cruz well I left in 1968 when
I was hired at the age of 19 by the San
Jose Mercury as a reporter I moved over
to Silicon Valley lived there for the
five years that I was on their staff and
I was the youngest reporter when I was
hired I was the English reporter when I
left and then I went to the University
of Chicago on a fellowship went to
Michigan to the State Capitol where I
was the Detroit Free Press is
investigative reporter there and then
the Los Angeles Times hired me as a
national investigative reporter based in
San Francisco and we moved back to Santa
Cruz and I commuted 75 miles to work on
the days that I actually had to drive to
the office did you ever get a degree in
there no I went into college on the GI
Bill because my dad was a hundred
percent disabled veteran and after the
first quarter of college a guy sitting
next to me
hey you know they got these things
called 300-level classes you just have
to talk your way into them and so I did
six years of college work six years of
college credits but they were all junior
senior and graduate school and when I
went in at Michigan State when my GI
Bill money ran out and asked for degree
they said oh you have to go back and
take all these freshman and sophomore
courses and I said to heck with it I got
a very good education but when did you
get interested in tax well you know we
all pay taxes first of all I mean the
very first time I paid any attention to
taxes was after I went to worked for the
San Jose Mercury Ronald Reagan had been
elected governor of California and said
we're not going to have withholding
because taxes should hurt and I hadn't
had to pay state income tax until I went
to work and I had this guy who do my
taxes and he tell told me that I owed
the state of California hundred eight
dollars that was my take-home pay for
the week one hundred and eight dollars
in that hurt let me tell you guy with
two kids that hurt over the years I had
to write as a reporter about property
taxes and disputes about them and then
in 1983 after I finished my coverage of
the LAPD I began writing about charities
that's when c-span first had me on to
talk about big foundations and things
and I began writing about estate tax
things when I went to the left the LA
Times and I went to the Philadelphia
Inquirer to write about the casino
industry jean-robert's the legendary
editor of The Enquirer and I talked a
lot about taxes and how he'd like to
have a different kind of coverage of
taxes and when he was brought back by
the New York Times he was the first
outsider brought back in a senior post
since carving and Oh which i think was
in 1912 or 1904 he brought me along with
a number of other investigative
reporters into the New York Times and we
had this idea that we were going to do a
running investigation of the tax system
and we were going to look at how the tax
system actually operates as opposed to
what the politicians say about in this
story I read in the your competitor to
Washington Post it said there are so
close two hundred thousand employees at
the IRS with a budget of over ten
billion dollars but yet people say and
then the other thing I want to ask you
about in this story was that this Oh
sideboard so first time they've ever had
a report like this issued such a
critique what is the Oversight Board
well it's not the first time in 1997 to
1998 Congress held hearings staged by
the late Senator Roth that asserted that
the IRS was an out-of-control agency
senators nickels and Murkowski and Lott
referred to the IRS says you know
gestapo-like and out of control and
there was a lot of talk of jackbooted
thugs and you recall there were IRS
people who appeared behind screens it
turned out when the Wall Street Journal
tax notes magazine the paper in Richmond
the New York Times and some other
journalists dug into these cases that in
fact things were not at all as they
appeared most of the people who appeared
testimony was not to be believed in the
congressional investigating agency the
General Accounting Office came to the
same conclusion but as part of the
outcome of those hearings Congress
passed a law and it created this
independent oversight board and the
oversight board has several times in the
past said to Congress that the IRS does
not have enough money to do the job now
ten billion dollars sounds like a lot of
money except they're collecting over two
trillion dollars the IRS has about
12,000 auditors today well back in 1988
it had over 16,000 almost 17,000
auditors and there are a lot more
taxpayers than there's a lot bigger
economy just to bring enforcement back
to where it was in 1988 you would after
more than double the number of auditors
at the IRS you would have to more than
double the number of criminal
investigative agents there are fewer
than 3,000 criminal investigative agents
and you would need to radically increase
the number of tax collectors or called
revenue officers because we've
essentially cut in half our commitment
to collecting taxes fairly and because
of changes that have taken place in the
economy among the better off Americans
those who rather than depending on wages
own their own businesses their investors
and partnerships their landlords
especially those operate in the
international arena there's been a
collapse of law enforcement and
throughout the book I named people who
don't pay taxes or who were caught in
some cases criminally caught by the IRS
and they weren't even made to pay 78% of
known cheaters in partnerships are not
made to pay I there's a man I write
about in the book Jerry Curnutt who is a
bureaucrat was a bureaucrat at the IRS
his job was to find cheating and
partnerships he couldn't find him
and one day somebody shows him a tax
return and he looks at it and he
realizes that a ten dollar investment is
going to cost the government I think
it's 300 million or five hundred million
dollars in taxes enormous amount of
money and he figures out a solution and
it's gonna cost less than $100,000 a
year Jerry says maybe less than twenty
thousand dollars a year nobody has the
money in their budget and so for want of
that little bit of money and changing
one question on one tax form the
government is giving up six seven ten
billion dollars a year of revenue from
the highest income people in America all
of whom are cheating and they're just
not being caught fundamentally the IRS
is completely an out-of-date agency when
I started writing about about the IRS in
the mid-50s IRS agents were using ms-dos
they didn't have Windows on their laptop
computers I've talked to IRS agents
whose desks are literally propped up
with law books there's almost no money
for training and database searches and
other tools that you need to identify
tax cheats what's the diff score the
diff score is a very simple crude
analytical tool to find likely
candidates for audit it simply looks at
your income class it looks at the
averages of deductions for those people
who itemize on their tax return and it
picks the outliers it's based on data
from surveys the IRS used to do until
Congress prohibited them the data is now
from the 1980s so it's way out of date
and the economy is much different now
than it was 20 years ago and today if
you get called in for an audit there's a
2/3 chance you'll pay more money there's
a one-third chance that you will either
have your return approved as submitted
or you'll get money
unbelievably inefficient and it's
because the data on which the disk score
is based is out of tune in the new
technology the IRS is supposed to get
they should be designing very
sophisticated statistical tools to catch
all sorts of cheating that involve high
high degree of reliability in the
ability to identify patterns of tax
cheating but I'm not at all confident
that we're going to see that because
Congress has been so tight fisted with
money for new technology if you could
get all the cheaters and all those
people who avoid tax either legal or
whatever what's the gap well the
official number in the oversight board
report is 311 billion dollars and since
the income tax system brings in less
than one and a half trillion it brings
in about I think 1.3 trillion last year
that's an enormous amount of money
that's both corporate and individual
income taxes I think that number is a
conservative number and historically we
thought of the of the tax gap as being
people at the bottom you know the the
guy who cuts lawns and gets paid in cash
that underground cash economy but one of
the things that I shown perfectly legal
is that a lot of the underground economy
is at the top it's in involves people
with enormous incomes who are not
reporting these incomes or are under
reporting them I've talked to IRS
criminal agents who told me about tax
returns for guys that showed the 90
hundred thousand dollar incomes they
look absolutely clean as could be and in
fact these guys are spending millions of
dollars a year on their lifestyle by
using offshore debit cards and credit
cards and other devices let me ask you
about the bipartisan here you've got two
names that you write about in the book
Jon Snow the current Treasury secretary
and Terry McAuliffe the current head of
the Democratic National Committee and I
don't think I'm entering a call from the
book yeah it's in a relationship to gary
Winnick and Global Crossing yes eighteen
million dollars yes that's right now
remember I'm sorry yes yeah but what
what were you getting at with Jon Snow
or Terry McAuliffe what's what's the
story there behind those well the last
substance chapter in the book
about what's happening to retirement
plans and Global Crossing is very much
caught up in that Global Crossing
existed for three years it had total
revenues during that period of about 200
million dollars which were essentially
advanced payments for services to be
provided later for this worldwide
network of undersea cables that they
were laying the stock market valued the
company at 52 billion dollars at the
peak
that's more than Ford Motor Company more
than General Motors on this tiny amount
of revenue the insiders of that company
cashed out 5.2 billion dollars that's
200 million dollars revenue we took five
point two billion dollars in stock
profits that's astonishing
Global Crossing had lots of friends in
high places and because it existed as
long as it did I don't think they'll
ever be any prosecutions in Global
Crossing unlike many of the other
companies who've seen but as part of the
strategy of Global Crossing they bought
the telephone company in Rochester and
the workers in Rochester were then
offered one of these quote unquote
modern pension plans 401k type pension
plans and they were told again and again
and again we're all going to be
millionaires
these linemen who come to your house and
install phones and stuff you're all
gonna be million it's where you live
that's right look Rochester telephone
company was how big oh the Union had
maybe fourteen hundred people in the de
filma thousand were on the payroll and
the rest were retired did you know these
some of these people yourself not until
I started writing about okay I tell
about a young man named John puznowski
who's the first person in his family to
graduate from college and after
graduating college he decides with a
finance degree to go to work for the
phone company as a lineman just like dad
did because even though he's young he
says gee I'm gonna have this pension I
can retire at 55 I can go hunting and
fishing and take whatever kids I have
when I get married and have time with
them and have a pretty nice life
and this under the company's pension
plan if you went to work for Global
Crossing as a lineman in 1960 and
retired 1995 35-year career you'd get
about $19,000 a year for the rest of
your life under the modern plan had it
been in effect I show this one's
supposed to make you a millionaire and
assuming that they had earned the
average returns for the stock market
over that time not the actual suppressed
returns of regulated utility company you
would have left with a maximum of
$120,000 so you have gone six gross
money so you would have collected your
the equivalent your pension for six
years and been broke and the point about
companies like Global Crossing is that
these new modern pension plans are a
prescription for disaster they impose an
expectation that ordinary workers can
manage their money very well if managing
money was easy everybody would be rich
everybody would own a yacht it's not the
average job on Wall Street even when you
count the clerks and janitors pays four
times the average salary in New York
what does that tell you about how hard
it is to manage money and Terry
McAuliffe's eighteen million out of here
in it he received stock in the company
for some work he did for them it went up
in value
he's disputed whether he sold at the
peak when it was worth 18 million but
he's never really tell people exactly
what what it was that that he did but it
is one of the few sorts of deals like
that that got into the public record and
that we know about there are lots of
these deals where people in political
life are feeding off the business
community and they're taking care of
each other and and we are not seeing
either of the political parties worrying
about the ordinary people in this
country and after all what is our
Constitution say is the reason we
created this country in the preamble it
says to promote the general welfare and
both that document and the declaration
events talk about freedom we created
America so that we would have freedom to
choose what we want to do wealth turns
out to be a byproduct of freedom and
it's terrific we have wealth but the
reason we created the country wasn't to
manipulate it to make money and to shift
burdens onto people who are not well
equipped to deal with them what was the
story about our Treasury secretary John
snow he used to be at CSX do you
remember that one yeah I do not it's a
retirement story so one of these you
know what's the goodies at the end of
the road well snow is one of many
executives I've written about who bill
up these unbelievable untaxed fortunes
in their systems anyway just interrupt
me all this is perfectly legal is the
title of your book that's correct there
I mean there are things obviously I read
about they're illegal people who have
offshore accounts that are undeclared
which makes them tax crimes but many of
the devices that I described are
perfectly legal and well I don't
remember the details of snows account
let me deal the fellow who's I know much
better
Roberto good sweater was the head of the
coca-cola company and during the first
dozen years he ran that company
stockholders did fabulously well the
average annual return was more than
thirty percent when the long-term
average returned for big companies is
around eleven but he amassed a billion
dollar untaxed fortune through one of
these executive deferred compensation
plans and in fact when we originally
first reported that in the New York
Times there were members the board of
directors the company who didn't realize
that he had a billion dollars there are
lots of executives out there who have
four or five hundred million billion
dollar untaxed fortunes which means
they're deferring the taxes in the
future they matter to ordinary Americans
for this reason imagine that Brian
you're running a c-span it's a publicly
traded company instead of the nonprofit
cooperative that it is and the cable
companies decide to pay you 105 million
dollars next year you take five million
of it in cash to live on you pay the
taxes on it and after your state and
local taxes got about three million
dollars left and you should be able to
pretty good life on that especially with
the kind of expense account that goes
with that jump the other hundred million
you leave on deposit with the company
you don't pay taxes on it the company
invests it on your behalf now if they
use it as working capital for the
company that's different but in most
cases that's not what happens they put
in an account on your behalf the company
doesn't get to deduct that money it has
to pay income taxes on it thirty five
million dollars so to pay you 105
million cost the company 140 million
dollars well you do that of the number
two guy goes that and the number seven
guy and all the way down or maybe the
the 50th or in this it's a really big
company the 3000th guy in the company
the company is this huge tax bill it can
only pay that bill by doing one of two
things one thing is to buy illegal tax
shelters that's part of the reason
there's this market and companies are
willing to do things that they know they
shouldn't be doing there
proper will pay Ernst & Young KPMG
Pricewaterhouse delete - char Thor
Anderson five million dollars and then
we'd have to pay the thirty five million
dollars in taxes all these companies now
say they're getting out of that business
then they go to the workers and they say
gee guys you know we just can't afford
your health care plan anymore we can't
afford your retirement plan anymore
we're gonna have to get rid of that
defined benefit pension plan that you've
been working on and we're going to give
you one of these modern pension plans
that's going to make you rich and which
will cost us 10 cents on the dollar or
maybe 30 cents on the dollar compared to
the old plan it's not competition from
the company down the street that's
making the company take away your fringe
benefits it's competition from guys in
the executive office and from the way
the tax system works that's taking those
benefits away from you and ordinary
Americans do not know that they don't
understand that I've talked to union
leaders who've been negotiating
contracts who didn't have a clue that
this is what was going on until they
read my book now they understand much
better how executive compensation is
much larger than it appears in the
published reports its tax driven and
it's having a devastating effect on
middle-class Americans you said before
we started that John Kerry is read read
this book well Carey told knight-ridder
newspapers in February that he was
stopping campaigning for a weekend so
that he could as he said veg out and
read two books and one of them was
perfectly legal and then on March 12th
when he was at home in Boston Kerry went
to a Borders bookstore and he bought
seven books including perfectly legal
which he had the store manager go get
for him off the shelf why do you think
somebody like him would learn in this
book that wouldn't make a difference
he's been in the Senate for like 19
years yes but he's not a tax specialist
and I know I think his understanding of
the tax system is the same as every
other member of Congress who isn't a tax
specialist and most Americans and we all
live in the same society and the
societal myths that shape our lives are
all the same and as someone who's
married to a woman of great wealth and
who is himself a wealthy man though not
in her League he's paid substantial
taxes and most of us believe that
whoever is better off and further up the
income ladder than we are pays more than
we do
and so one shocking thing he certainly
would learn is that that's not true
secondly I think he would learn how our
governments practices on the way we tax
businesses favor multinational companies
the General Motors of the world against
domestic companies if you're a purely
domestic company and that's what most
big entrepreneurial businesses are in
America you're getting clobbered by the
tax system compared to your
multinational competitors why because we
have something called the foreign tax
credit you know you'll hear companies
say well there's double taxation they
tax the service season they taxes it
that's not true
you get a dollar-for-dollar deduction on
taxes paid to a foreign government so
every time an American company pays the
communist government in China $1 in
taxes they don't get $1 deduction here
they get $1 reduction in their taxes if
we eliminated that system and went to a
pure territorial tax system just what
profits did you earn inside the United
States corporate taxes would rise six or
seven billion dollars a year none of the
big companies want to end that system
the multinational companies because it's
a subsidy program for them then which
they voiced it on just as with
individuals they voiced it on to people
further down the chain secondly we have
a system that encourages companies to
move capital out of the United States if
if you're a chemist and you come up with
a formula and suddenly say gee you know
that we put one of the people rub this
on their face yesterday and suddenly
they were beautiful
I mean imagine what you could get for
that drug the drug company would sit you
down with lawyers right that moment they
would put everything that you know about
that drug into a letter they would send
it off to a company subsidiary in
Switzerland or some other tax haven they
would pay for the value of that letter
maybe they'd pay a million dollars for
it imagine the real value of you could
come up with that you know face cream
and then every time a jar of that face
cream is sold a royalty will be paid
it'll be an expense on the US tax system
it'll take the profits outside of the
United States it'll put them in a place
where they'll never be taxed and the
company will build up this huge offshore
a reservoir of untaxed money and
wherever the capital goes the jobs
ultimately have to go so
Republicans Democrats one party or the
other do better with this no the
Democrats and we haven't talked much
about them but the Democrats started
this practice of over taxing the middle
class to benefit the super-rich with
what they did to Social Security and the
Republicans have simply taken that ball
and run with it what they did is Social
Security well we used to pay as you go
we paid as much each year as was paid
out in benefits at beginning in 1983
when the Democrats are in control of
Congress we've been overpaying we've
overpaid 1.8 trillion dollars so far and
it will get much bigger that money was
used to finance tax cuts for the
wealthiest people in America they will
eventually have to borrow pay back that
money by redeeming Treasury notes that
are in the load that so-called lockbox
and Paul O'Neill by the way the Treasury
secretary is my authority on this among
others but what the wealthy got was a
30-year delay in paying those taxes
before they have to pay them back well a
dollar I can pay 30 years from now is
not very expensive I and you pay the
dollar today and then we get the benefit
30 years from now we are transferring
the time value of that money to the very
wealthiest people in America and that's
why their incomes are exploding like
this as I show in the book and ordinary
Americans incomes are stagnant you talk
about a woman named Kate Barton of the
Ernst & Young Boston office yeah Kate
Barton do well the fires are still
burning at Ground Zero the stock market
is in the dump and Kate Barton of Ernst
and Young in a webcast a big corporate
client says we have a solution for you
we have a get rich plan that only works
because the stock market is down all you
have to do is move your company
headquarters on paper to Bermuda and you
can stop paying us corporate income
taxes and you just pay the Bermudian x'
about $27,000 a year and by the way she
says some people might not like this
idea because of what just happened
9/11 shortly before but she says perhaps
patriotism should take a backseat to
profits I mean that's just a perfect
example of people who want to take
advantage of all the benefits that we
by having our free society that people
fought and died to have and to sustain
and they don't care about anything but
their pocketbook and I want America to
endure I don't want my children or my
grandchildren or people who won't know
about me 500 years from now whoever my
descendents to ever sit in a classroom
in high school and pick up a book that
says the United States of America was
but if we don't keep in mind that we
have to promote the general welfare we
will see more and more people giving up
on democracy not caring caring more
about who Jennifer Lopez is sleeping
with and who their congressman is we
will see more incidents like although
hopefully not as horrific as Oklahoma
City we will see more and more people
expressing the view that the federal
government is a criminal organization
and I've written many stories the New
York Times about people who are
expressing these views but go back to
Kate Barton for a moment no did she
succeed well a number of companies have
gone to Bermuda it's it's perfectly
legal they're generally not household
names they're industrial companies with
a few exceptions Stan Lee works tried to
go but to do it they had to rig the
election they got caught they didn't get
to go
who Stan Lee works as you probably have
their tools in your home they make hand
tools and hinges and automatic door
openers and their competitor Ingersoll
Rand went so in the areas where they
compete with each other like automatic
door openers Ingersoll Rand now has a
tax advantage against Stan Lee works how
does it work you turn what were profits
in the United States into tax deductible
expenses that you send overseas in the
form of interest on debt royalties for
intellectual property is when I
discussed the face cream and you take
the company logo and other properties
and and put them offshore and and if you
have existing ones you create new ones
to imbue them with value management fees
and other devices so that you basically
remove from the US what would be taxable
profits and reduce and and if you're
really good at it completely eliminate
your corporate income tax panama the
cayman islands a lot of other places you
mentioned Bermuda Barbados all do the
same thing yes
although Bermuda is the place of choice
for two reasons
it has a set of laws and a legal
practice that is one-sided and benefits
corporations you basically can't sue a
company successfully in Bermuda as you
can hear and secondly we have a treaty
with Barbados so these companies that go
to Bermuda become resident in Barbados
their Bermuda companies resident
Barbados that's what ingersoll-rand is
they have one guy down there they hold
one meeting a year in Barbados and under
a US tax treaty they can suck all these
profits out of the US as tax deductible
expenses explain this if I understand it
correctly if the IRS sues you that can't
be public if used to the IRS it is
public that's exactly right what's that
mean well it's what is meant in practice
is it's turned out to be a huge benefit
both for the IRS covering up its
mistakes but I think much more
importantly for serious tax cheats an
IRS guy named Bradley Herbert figured
out from an audit in the 90s that Enron
had become a fraud and he wanted to
stick by an audit that disallowed all
search of deductions to Enron which
would have forced them to sue the IRS in
court and would have made this public
and everyone would have known well in
advance it was a fraud the National
office of the IRS shut him down ordered
that Enron get the tax breaks that it
wanted and as a result and Ron went on
its merry way until the disaster struck
in 2001 2000 we used to have a system in
which tax returns were public record we
I have clips from the 1920s Julius and
Rosenwald founder the Sears & Roebuck
chain went to the Internal Revenue
Bureau in Chicago and paid his taxes of
1 million one hundred eleven thousand
dollars yesterday
up until the Nixon era it was public
record whether you'd filed your tax
return now that's all secret and one of
the few specific reforms I do recommend
is that we create a public register that
tells whether or not you filed a tax
return and we pay serious reward for
people through for turning in those who
haven't filed and police after all the
IRS the tax please pay informants all
the time
lots of people would be added to the tax
rolls if we go just a couple minutes you
also talked about the ability for
somebody who's very rich to go into a
lawyer the lawyer writes it may charge
them a million dollars for some kind of
a letter
right that gets them a tax key right
what's that well when you buy a tax
shelter that you especially if you know
it's not going to work if the government
finds out about it's a bad tax shelter
you pay for one of these opinion letters
and they're like a treasure map where x
marks the unstack spot they're often 50
to 80 pages long I've read a number of
them and they have enough caveats in
them to sink a galleon and after all
caveat doesn't weigh anything but you
use that letter if your tax shelter gets
demolished to say well don't charge me
penalties don't charge me any penalties
and so if that happens what happens if
you get caught all you do is pay the
taxes in the interest you're in the same
position you would have been except for
the fee you paid for the letter it is a
system that encourages tax cheating and
the administration just proposed a rule
to shut down tax shelters by saying
we're gonna charge promoters half of
their fees well shown down let's charge
them three times their fees if they
promote an illegal tax shelter that'll
put them out of business when all said
and done this perfectly legal book will
sell how many copies do you think how
long has it been on the market it's been
out since January 4th it's been on the
Wall Street Journal bestseller list for
two months the New York Times list for
six weeks an extended list for another
three or four I don't know how many
it'll sell what I hope it does is have
caused enough Americans to understand
how our tax system really works that
Congress has to pay attention to
ordinary Americans to what's happening
to them in our tax system so that we get
a tax system that greases the wheels of
commerce rewards drivers promotes social
stability and makes America endure as we
near April the 15th there's the cover of
the book
perfectly legal David Cay Johnston of
the New York Times thank you very much
thank you